hey reject nation its Greg here and I'm
John we've been asked by quite a few
people to comment on the Disney Foxx
deal which has apparently been struck up
it's gonna take home and didn't take
like maybe a year year and a half
basically eighteen months actually what
I heard was what it would take to go
through a right first we gotta wait for
a weed to get legal we don't get the we
voted for the weed deal they go through
it doesn't mean this protocol I feel
like on the one hand that's good cuz
part of that is what they have to make
sure this is all legal
yeah which I'm like sure cuz Disney is
alarmingly big I would love it if they
guess I shoot the New Mutants all you
wanted art Phoenix can I believe they
bought it for a whopping three trillion
dollars billions upon billions of
dollars it cause I think 50 billion yeah
something was huge the final thing it
was like it was billed at sixty for a
while and then someone was even like oh
it's closer to 70 and I think they
locked it a 56 or something like that
the interesting thing about this deal
that I think people are ever thinking
about is Fantastic Four x-men yes this
all people seem to be thinking about one
like Fox makes a labels and like other
divisions I think it was the best choice
they could do I wonder if this was part
of Disney and Mark cuz I know Disney
bought them but I'm sure Marvel had a
say in it because Marvel is like they
they're all some of the biggest
properties there's our left wit box
right now I'm sure that I wouldn't have
been surprised if that was near the
front of the conversation is sort of
like yeah it's in the money if we could
put these characters yeah I mean in
terms of the comic-book aspect I feel
like I'm the only world war we
are the only ones on the internet who
are like not too thrilled about the
x-men being in the MS I'm like not
either am I looking forward to seeing
some of them in there totally like I
love to see like Cyclops or Wolverine if
anything I think that there's a lot of
characters the x-men franchise has not
done great justice for this specifically
like Cyclops and even rogue for that
matter as big as Anna Paquin was in that
role like that it's not the rogue I grew
up with bro could fly she had attitude
yes southern charm and another thing too
but the x-men franchise they're all like
black suited out or first-class I have a
yellow and then in the Wolverine dad
it's deleted scene yeah yeah one thing
I've always said about the x-men
franchise that there's or people have
asked in what movie do you think you
could remake I think that for rebooting
Wolverine with Hugh Jackman clearly out
of it even comped it on this saying that
he doesn't think at all he'll actually
be part of this I've said that if
there's one way you could reboot
Wolverine redo the origin tale because
no one likes it everyone would like a
remake of that [ __ ] yeah so you can
reintroduce Wolverine and I think you
could bring the x-men and bring it into
a colorful palette because the x-men is
very colorful and I think they have a
lot of very specifically distinct
personalities that at the time one the
x-men franchise began you couldn't go as
diverse as distinct as colorful so
there's definitely a lot of pros I see
that could occur with having the x-men
in there at the same time though they're
probably just gonna become Marvel movies
because while the aesthetic and the
comic-book flare was lacking in terms of
how MCU does their films as compared to
the x-men films the x-men films still
have a distinct style and a lot and they
are more bold there's a Logan film out
there and a Deadpool and the New Mutants
trailer seeing that alone is like wow
these are very different and some of the
sequels and prequels like first-class
very different Days of Future past the
way they do it is it feels like
filmmaking not to say the MCU doesn't do
that I'm just saying that but they all
have a likeness yeah they're all have
distinctions in the way they're done
very specifically the you can go all out
and do something crazy Lee different
like just look at the last three
examples of Logan Deadpool and you
mutants I haven't seen you it looks very
oh yeah and it's always been building
yeah they're a horror movie you know cuz
I feel like with the MCU you get you get
variety for sure you get yours cosmic
eye guardians and Ragnarok then you get
your spider-man your Iron Man the thing
is they all feel like they're all under
one umbrella still they take aesthetic
cues from other genres yeah take you
know tonal tonal cues but they are all
still similar stories at the end of it
yeah whereas I feel like the the x-men
movies kind of tell different stories
each time and I don't know how Marvel
has ordered because Marvel's like we
have 48 thousand movies planned for the
next ten years you know yeah yeah and
I'm like well now that they have this
deal I don't know if when they plan this
they were already like well if we get to
this point we can buy the properties but
we can we'll find a way to get the
property back so maybe having the x-men
in there and Fantastic Four was already
part of their potential ideas of what
they would want to do with that went
after infinity war and in a new war part
2 whatever it's called comes out because
that's supposed to mark the end of a
Phase three in the beginning of a new
wave of the MCU maybe that was already
part of their plan maybe having x-men in
there will fit perfectly to what they
had in mind with them also saying that
they wanted to make a completely
different revamp on it the x-men is a
world of mutants it's a world of
superpowers so if you have the x-men and
they're you would have to change the
human world these superheroes live in
you would have to you would almost have
to introduce it because it would be so
hard to retcon yeah and you and you
can't honor x-men without having the
human world be a variety of mutants
hiding and people hating mutants yeah
like it's not x-men if you don't have
that because it's the whole point of
x-men that element out of it all is the
most bummer II to me on the surface
level because yeah I've always liked
having these properties at Fox my ideal
world would be like strike of an
agreement like you did with Sony or
something yeah and so that's what what
suggest to me that there are other
interests in mind than just this I
imagine I don't know how many of the
people they're gonna take but I imagine
in absorbing one studio they'll have the
same kind of amount of personnel they'll
just get bigger and so they could
theoretically make separate movies that
you know can coincide with their already
schedule I feel like they could really
do fantastic for them if anyone could do
fantastic for its marble yeah and in
terms of marble I I do kind of get
conflicted again because I'm like well
these are Marvel's characters at the end
of the day and it's weird that that you
know somebody else should be like no no
no we own this one you can't have it and
it is yours even if that is how rights
work I guess it feels more natural but
in terms of the rest of it I am nervous
for what this means for the greater film
marketplace I feel like you could bring
exponent then also what about the Arden
material they're providing now like New
Mutants and the Deadpool franchise the
big concern is Disney gonna still allow
you to do the r-rated and hits that have
been coming out of Fox or are they gonna
go all Disney on us and they might go
all Disney on us but I'm thinking if
Disney wants to sustain this or really
keep it something special
Disney has to evolve to and be willing
to do edgier content well I don't feel
like that's beyond Disney now because of
all the studios around it seems like
Disney's stuff usually has a certain
level of solidness even if you hear like
a rogue one got a whole bunch of stuff
so came out pretty solid the movies are
the movies are great but in terms of our
written material that is the main
concern I have is are they gonna stick
to the hard art I don't know cuz part of
me does feel like they're smart enough
now Disney seems like they have judgment
enough to know that that is a major
asset you can't look at something like
Deadpool and just ignore that or Logan
or anything like that my hope would
definitely be that they don't ignore it
as if they turn it all into Marvel
movies
I think that's gonna hurt because that's
just gonna make it more in flux of the
same thing I don't think that's a good
idea I think they should just kind of
keep the Deadpool thing going yeah I
think I think they should sleep the
Deadpool thing going before this deal
happened there was already plans for
other x-men films additional sequels and
whatnot and now I'm thinking well
they're kind of rapping filming on a lot
of things right now New Mutants is
already done I think I'm sure they
wanted that to be a franchise is that
franchise that's gonna go down the drain
now are they gonna redo the things that
Fox has already set in motion with
certain franchises are they gonna put
them in a position we're like no you
gotta end it you gotta add Dark Phoenix
you gotta in Deadpool you got any
mutants because we got to redo this long
I don't you
like that would have they released me
statements there's a car horn have you
they released any statements about their
intent for any of this stuff I don't
think so
I feel like again that would be kind of
a dumb decision to grab already sailing
ships and then sink them yourself in
favor of starting from scratch you like
Disney's got the judgment not to do that
well I think the reason why people worry
about that is because of the spider-man
franchise because they had amazing
spider-man 1 & 2 and instead of bringing
Andrew Garfield over I think they
already was Sony already wanted out of
it because they saw some amazing
spider-man 2 was a flop and it wasn't
like a tech like big flop but it
technically didn't perform underwhelming
yeah I think that's why people might are
speculating too that they might just do
that
like what does this mean for all this is
basically the question but there's other
films outside of the comic book world
like Fantastic Four would be great but
there's other films like the Avatar
franchise and James Cameron's from
working on that sequel this is for like
ever and that might affect it in some
way maybe I kind of feel like avatar
would fit under the Disney umbrella
pretty solid doesn't Fox have like an
independent company Fox Searchlight yeah
the thing about this story throughout to
me is is again yeah like like we said
and we've spent a good amount of time
talking about Marvel and and big thing
everyone wants to hear about yeah but
but the thing that strikes me first is
just how Fox is one of the og studio
they were one of the og innovators which
is a bummer to me even back in the early
days of cinema man like he was pushing
the technology and and you know
fostering that stuff and so to see that
fall or to get absorbed by something as
a bummer but also it's such a huge
studio with Fox Searchlight underneath
it and so many kinds of yeah like so
many feel cuz this isn't a big
money-making game it's like what Walter
White says there in the Empire business
you know Fox Searchlight doesn't seem
like something that they would really
give a [ __ ] about like what would be the
point and then doing that well means I
think I keep it going the way it is
because Fox Searchlight makes some
pretty damn good movies they do but
Disney is all doing all this for profit
and they need to make sure their profit
after spending billions of dollars their
first plan of action is gonna be
whatever we do now with under the Fox
umbrella or whatever that was we gotta
make sure we're making a [ __ ] ton of
money right now
cuz movies spent a lot of money so maybe
Fox Searchlight will do some stuff
eventually but I don't think they're
gonna be concerned about that in the
beginning I think right away they're
gonna be like x-men Deadpool Fantastic
Four how do we make this all work you
know that has to be the major reason
they bought it it has to be what other
incentive would they really have to buy
it well and and all of their assets I
mean I don't know how the rights I don't
know how the copyright I read it all
works I was a part of the whole deal I
understand all the absorb the box you
know that just means like any money that
flows through their movies well now
somehow flow through it is yeah well and
this is such a high caliber of business
that like it kind of hurts my brain cuz
I'm like there's so many I get why this
is gonna take 18 months to figure out
because there are so many assets and
departments and people and and you know
level that's that's the other concern
too is [ __ ] jobs if somebody is gonna
lose their job oh well I think oh what
are you gonna hare it the entire Fox
appointees lot like no way they're gonna
do that I don't know cuz again I don't
really know what their motivation is
like this is was a bewildering story for
me to hear about the first time just
that they were thinking of this because
Fox is one of the Titans they they
should reboot the die-hard friendship
make it family-friendly and put it
around Christmas again like when someone
buys all your stuff like they're gonna
start doing things with some of it
another big change for 2017 where I'm
like wow man I I don't know how this is
gonna I don't have a word for what I am
to see if I was Disney I'd I get to work
on all the reboots right away I say redo
the first six Star Wars now that you
owned them reboot home alone reboot cast
away the Martian the movies under the
Disney umbrella I could totally work I
mean Kung Fu Panda I could even see
Simpsons working Ice Age Alvin and the
Chipmunks there's other movies outside
of the compo ones that work one I hope I
have I guess for this is that seeing at
least how Marvel and Lucasfilm and
Disney all function together it seems
like Disney concerned with keeping you
know Star Wars Star Wars and keeping
Marvel
marvels that element gives me some
modicum of hope that maybe they'll take
these assets and go we don't want to
work these we want to keep them
successful I guess maybe they'll change
somehow but not become completely Disney
fide will Ridley Scott be able to
continue his alien prometheus thing
maybe Neill Blomkamp will finally be
able to make I will get the list of the
11 movies Fox released in 2017 and
there's a few where I'm like I could see
this transferring over boss baby I could
even see planet the age says it's
already a pg-13 franchise and Captain
Underpants died with a kid Kingsman
that's another one that I'm concerned
about because the other thing too is
that they're inheriting franchises now
too you know their hair any plan of the
apes are inheriting Kingsman Captain
Underpants we're gonna be learning
stress or trying to get a sequel for
that really yeah for reals
yeah to murder tumors on the - I see
like good matters that seem like they
would go well for Disney I also think
that right now what Disney will be focus
on is what they've always been focusing
on the past few years which is franchise
building they don't make a movie without
wanting to make a franchise even if it's
a Beauty and the Beast I'm sure even
they're there trying to get a sequel out
of that isn't that one of the line of
print of classic princess movies brought
to live-action
yes it's like a non established
franchise in and of itself
I'm looking at Fox's list of movies at
release are we gonna get more original
content like the boss baby this list
making out oh I can see why Fox is here
like oh yeah I can see how they're not
this isn't a dynamite Logan and most
people won't agree but I think Kingsman
is is a credit to this list and I heard
good things about Captain Underpants
actually but yeah the rest are all
middling well guys are you excited for
the Disney Fox deal
are you worried they're gonna ruin your
r-rated Marvel films variety is your
asset to use it I can't wait till Disney
buys Warner Bros
and Sony no no Sony's the only one left
what is the only one that won't keep
spider-man will take all your venom
rights I can't wait till the Disney buys
Google know I feel like Google is one of
the few people who maybe could could
withstand that if you're worried about
family-friendly content on YouTube wait
till Disney buzz thank you Oh welfare if
Disney walked through the door right now
maybe you can subscribe follow us on
social media you can check out our
patreon it's become like a second
youtube channel we reply a lot on there
so check us out over there becomes the
charger today over there over there over
there and download a false in the start
us app almost that 2200 followers right
now we're posting regularly over their
regular